hello and welcome to video playing of a
ski mask hmm 93 ok have a decent score
against him 4 out of 5 no particular
memory what the games were like so get
ur h three kings inion ok
h6 is not considered to be particularly
great against Bishop g5 and said
weakness often as long-term consequences
weakness of age 6 g 6 and so on and c5
well black should try for some counter
play but he doesn't blocking the Queen
side is so very welcome ok um night d 34
or group g1 they both make sense i think
i'll start with luke g1 queen age five
yep why not threaten on g7 threaten on
age 6
not sure I mean I could have played
night to D to your form
hmm yes so it's not so easy to give
black some advice what is he doing here
Knight f6 I go Queen edge form and no
sorry I'm taking the bishop and I'd have
six isn't playable this one okay okay I
don't mind an ending
really such a big issue how you take
here anyway I would have played this
pretty much regardless okay um I guess
III okie i can go King d2 Leonid f6 is
plundering the h6 pawn this is a nice
position for white very nice position
I've got more space and black has a
couple of weaker weak spots this
threatens night xe5 ok so now hmm I
think I might be five yeah I think once
night before annoying I'm preventing
this why not I've got time him so
it's just double on the g fo
Wow that move is possible it's hard to
believe 95 night f6 negative 6 is
strategically also very nice but ok 95
context Bishop f5 and that wins 95 53 I
don't see it I don't see it ok so 97
here I think for an exchange there is no
compensation
it gives me two exchanges
black resigns okay so let's have a look
that I think there are a couple of
things right in the opening age 6 i
think is slightly question when c5 is a
mistake just just the game mistake this
move because you have to try for some
kind of cult apply that same with 95-92
and a five or so something like this and
then this potentially then c6 a form
this is still a relatively normal
position I don't like age six so much
here for black but it's okay and this is
just not giving any counter player so I
think white is very well positioned with
g4 could have played g4 immediately
maybe that was even stronger and after
f5 I think why does white is in very
good shape Queenie h5 might be debatable
actually I'm I wasn't really sure
especially this move is something that
occurred to me only later I thought okay
I have Bishop h6 route 27 stuff but not
see too is a check the engine wants to
play rook c1 and give the exchange money
enough gives by the slight advantage
here even though I'm the exchange down
okay I mean this is the line the engine
gives hmm hard to believe that I should
be better well as stock recess but um
can you play this and after the Queen
trade the pollution is very nice and the
night only for is very strong black's
pieces are not very well coordinated III
was to be on the safe side let's say
yeah now
book III wasn't the only move but okay
it is okay i think yeah this loses the
house to 295 yeah this opening is really
dangerous if black plays it in a like
yeah this this kind of way wine very
often gets an overwhelming position
quickly and it was a prime example of
that okay thanks for watching